a really disturbing video has come out
of
kentucky a man was at a restaurant
he was shown pulling a gun
on a group of armed blm
activists you can see them there
mostly white you'll notice of the blm
activists but they're there they're
around his table screaming yelling at
him
it's hard to hear what he's he's just
standing there he's got the gun
nice pressed blue shirt nice chinos
standing very calmly saying get out of
here
lots of f-bombs going around really
really disturbing i can't tell you how
disturbed i am watching this
because that guy should have a way
bigger gun that that gun
is not big enough to take on an entire
armed mob
i mean it was i'm glad it worked out
everyone left it was peaceful
but we've gotta really start taking this
issue of justice
much more seriously folks i'm michael
knowles as the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from pepsi fifa
who says melinda and bill seeing each
other at coachella like
well bye yes i can totally see that
happening because by the logic of of
their divorce
that they just don't feel like you know
they can really grow
into their next phases of their lives
[Music]
together man you know and they just got
to find themselves and stuff
by that by that logic they are
definitely going to wind up at coachella
like a bunch of
i don't know 18 year old kids they're in
their 60s and 50s
but behaving like little children our
whole society is which is why our
society
is dying we'll get to that a little bit
uh later but
sometimes there's just there's so much
noise so much nonsense in society
you just gotta tune it all out really
focus in on something
important and when you want to do that
best way to do is with raycon
a lot of us are going to be on the move
again this summer so here's my advice
take your ray cons with you a pair of
rake on wireless earbuds in your ears
can make all the difference no matter
what you're listening to maybe you're
listening to an audiobook
i could name one good audiobook in
particular
maybe you are listening to music maybe
you're listening to your favorite
podcast i don't know you can get crisp
powerful beats at half the price of
other premium audio
brands raicons look great and feel even
better they come in a range of cool
colors
with customizable gel tips included for
a comfortable in-ear fit
right now raycon's offering 15
off all their products for our listeners
but here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy raycon dot com slash knowles
there you will get 15
off your entire raikon order it's such a
great deal you're going to want to buy
a pair and a spare that is 15
off at buy raycon dot com slash
knowles this very very superior product
go to byracon.com
knowles so you've got the blm mob
disturbing this poor man's dinner
on derby day in kentucky and that man
like a total
total gentleman like a total american he
stands up doesn't even wrinkle his shirt
hope his dinner didn't get too cold
pulls out what looks to be a derringer
or some really really small gun and just
says
not today guys sorry you think you can
come here with an armed mob
and push me around but that's not gonna
happen
this is america you're gonna show up
with
your arms i'm gonna pull out my arms and
you're gonna go away and that's exactly
exactly what happened but blm believes
that it can subvert our justice system
all around the country notably in the
case of
the george floyd trial the derek chauvin
trial into the the death of george floyd
there was a juror we were told the
jurors are not being influenced at all
by you know the most important news
story in the country that led to the
burning of multiple cities no they
weren't influenced at all
they don't have any opinions on this
very contentious topic they're totally
objective and disinterested right
except there's a photo that just came
out of one of the jurors wearing a blm
shirt that says get your knee off our
necks so it's referring directly
to the derrick chauvin incident with
george floyd
the photo was posted in august by this
juror's
uncle it was taken in washington dc
at an event commemorating martin luther
king
in many ways quite ironic you got to
throw this trial out it's ridiculous
derek chovin should not spend one more
second in
prison it
at so many stages of this process
there have been there has been a lot of
evidence to say
this is not fair this is not going to be
justice maxine waters threatening to
start riots if they don't get the
ridiculous
charges that they wanted the president
of the united states putting his thumb
on the scales
and now we find out that the jury was
rigged
that the juror who went in and said i
have no dog in this fight i don't have
any opinions i'm totally impartial
turns out he's a member of blm throw it
out
throw out the trial but michael what if
derek shoven did something wrong
what if he did isn't isn't the whole
argument for
among the criminal justice reformers
that it would be better to let 10 guilty
men go free than to have one innocent
man
in prison that we need to we need to err
on the side of leniency well i'm not
even saying air on the side of leniency
i'm just saying that people are entitled
to due process and if the due process is
not being recognized
then then you cannot keep the guy in
prison
you're probably not going to hear about
that that juror unless you're listening
to this show
maybe if you're reading a handful of
conservative outlets maybe you'll hear
about it but maybe you won't
why not because the systems of
justice and communication in this
country more importantly communication
probably
are rigged for the libs did you see
there was a story yesterday out
that a girl who cheated at a homecoming
queen election
is going to face jail time but those two
girls
who carjacked that poor pakistani guy
and killed him the other day
they're never going to see the inside of
a jail cell you remember that story we
covered it on this show too
why because the systems of justice
and the dominant narrative in this
country are rigged
in the liberal direction and i'm not
just talking about cnn we'll get to cnn
later
i'm not just talking about the
mainstream media i'm talking about the
new media too i'm talking about
the internet i'm talking about the whole
thing facebook i felt crossed the
rubicon
during the january 6th
insurrection the worst attack ever in
the history of our country
so much worse for those three hours of
the horn guy jumping on the desk
than when blm burned the country down
for eight months i know i'm that's what
i'm saying
i'm saying it was much worse i know hey
facebook sensors
youtube sensors i'm i'm agreeing with
you here i'm saying
that some lunatic guy in a horn hat
making a nuisance of himself in the
capital i'm saying that's much much
worse
than when blm killed people and looted
and burned down the country for six
months
we're agreeing we have to agree because
if we don't agree
you're gonna take me off of the internet
and because the internet is the public
square
and a handful of oligarchs control the
whole thing
so yeah good we're agreeing right if
only president trump had agreed
he wouldn't have been suspended that was
facebook crossing the rubicon
to suspend no matter what you think
about the 2020 election
at the time donald trump was the duly
elected sitting president of the united
states
and some nerd in silicon valley censored
him well michael
you're entitled to freedom of speech not
freedom of reach
build your own facebook build your own
public square in our republic build your
own
90 plus of
communication in this country which is
dominated by google
facebook and twitter you're not going to
do that that's not possible
and they decided that they were going to
control the political process if you are
not permitted on social media
you are not a viable political candidate
simple as that
even if you're donald trump even if you
are you're already the president you're
one of the most famous guys in the
country in the world
you still are going to have a big big
problem since
trump left office we haven't really
heard that much from him
and it's not because he hasn't sent out
notes he has but it's because
these oligarchs control communication
and they're not letting him speak and
yesterday the facebook oversight board
the
relatively independent body it's it's
independent as a matter of corporate
structure
but as a matter of politics it's far
left-wing the facebook oversight board
decided to uphold the trump ban on
facebook google and twitter don't have
similar oversight boards
so they're just going to keep it going
indefinitely now what the facebook
oversight board said was
at the time that zuckerberg decided to
suspend the newly elected sitting
president
that was totally right because you know
trump could have incited violence
maxine waters still on facebook kamala
harris
still on facebook the logic of the
facebook oversight board completely
collapsing
but they say it was totally justified
then however
the oversight board did not want to make
a final decision they said look you
facebook you've got to decide what's
going to happen to trump's account in
the long run
and we're going to give you six months
to do that but we don't want to make
that final decision now do you see
what's happening here
i don't want to just slam zuckerberg i
don't want to just slam the facebook
oversight board because what they're
dealing with is a perennial political
problem namely
no one wants to take ultimate
responsibility they want to wield power
they want things to go their way but
they don't want to have the
accountability for that
a very popular word these days
accountability so what does zuckerberg
say he says no no it's not me
i've got an independent board what does
the independent word say oh no it's not
us we've got to kick this back to the
executives and
they're just going to keep kicking it
back and forth so no one has to make a
decision
and everyone can maintain the status quo
which is in their favor
this is why
we need to weigh in charlie kirk came
out he sent out a tweet
that he got dragged for oh my gosh
everyone dunking on charlie here's what
he said the u.s supreme court should
overturn
the facebook oversight board's ruling
which upholds outlawing
the 45th president of the united states
from social media this is big tech
corporate oligarchy without standing
it's gone too far enough is enough
people dragging charlie for this
charlie you idiot you what you think
that the court
can overrule the facebook board they're
totally different things
you can't appeal the facebook board
ruling to the supreme court
what is charlie saying here we'll go
word by word what does he say
the the court the u.s supreme court
should overturn
the oversight board's ruling he puts
ruling in quotes because he's saying
it's not an actual judicial ruling
therefore we through the political
process
should restrain this allegedly private
company which controls
a huge proportion of our communications
from dominating our politics
of course that's true what charlie said
is absolutely right
and the conservatives have not
understood this because conservatives
have spent the last two decades shilling
for corporations
and pretending that there is this
perfectly neat and tidy distinction
between private and public between the
private company build your own twitter
and the public that's the government
government bad never good to use
politics even when the people give us
political power we should never
influence
politics or wield it in any way well
that that neat and tidy distinction
falls apart when facebook is dominating
the politics
complete we talked about this yesterday
this neat and tidy distinction between
private and public
falls apart if in our private lives we
decide
to engage in all manner of vice and and
sin
and we destroy our families and we abuse
our communities
well that has public effects just like
conservatives like to have this neat and
tidy distinction between culture
and politics it goes so far as it goes
but while culture influences politics
politics also influences culture while
the movies change our perception of our
country
the political structure changes our
perception
the political institutions rather change
our perception of the culture just look
at east germany
the reason that east germany is atheist
today and west germany is religious
is not because of regional variations in
bratwurst it's because of the political
systems that were there
for the duration of the cold war what is
charlie saying
what are what are all sensible
conservatives saying they're saying hey
court hey legislature hey department of
justice
hey any of our systems of of government
in this country
that we are we the people are empowering
fine yeah we are we're acting together
in politics
you've got to rein in these handful of
oligarchs
that are controlling our political
process an
urgent deeply conservative call by the
way if you want
serious conservative thought not just
the road
stale talking points you've got to check
out city journal for many many years
city journal one of my favorite outlets
if you're interested in learning more
about what's going on in our nation's
cities
and our culture you absolutely need to
be reading city journal published by the
manhattan institute city journal is the
nation's premier urban policy magazine
with
fabulous fearless writers such as my
friend heather mcdonald
such as christopher ruffo who's doing
excellent work on critical race theory
right now obviously they're publishing a
lot of other great writers dr glenn
lowry
nicole galenas kay heimowitz
steve malonga and even by the way do you
know a certain fellow by the name of
andrew clavin maybe you've heard of him
many many others right now for a limited
time my listeners can enter
for a chance to get their hands on a
print issue of city journal the magazine
for free
just go to cityhyphenjournal.org
giveaway enter your information and you
will be contacted if you were selected
that is
city hyphen cityhyphenjournal.org
giveaway cityhyphenjournal.org
giveaway senator cruz pointed out
the danger of this corporate oligarchy
controlling our politics
while charlie kirk was
talking to the conservatives senator
cruz was trying to
talk to the center and to the left he
said for every liberal
celebrating trump's social media ban if
the big tech oligarchs can muzzle the
former president
what's to stop them from silencing you
now i think this is a good pitch
but we have to be more specific
which is senator cruz says hey for all
the liberals
what do you think when they come for you
the thing is though i don't think that
big tech
is is going to come for the liberals i
don't think that big tech
is going to come for many of the
workstars who are just the pawns of the
liberal establishment
blm antifa they're just they're just the
puppets of the liberal establishment
i don't think that big tech is going to
come for them i think big tech is going
to come for any
any heterodox thinker and and that's
really what senator cruz is getting at
here
saying hey all you people who think
you're so open-minded you're so out of
the box
you question authority that which is
what all these people think they are
what happens when you really question
authority
what happens when you really start to
contradict the dominant liberal regime
you think that the enforcement arm the
the communications propaganda
enforcement arm of that regime is going
to take kindly to you
no they're going to treat you just like
they treated donald trump
or alex jones or whoever any of the
other conservatives
who have thought outside the box and
been banned
this should give serious pause to people
who have heterodox thoughts
and it should remind leftists from
the most buttoned-up liberal works at
goldman sachs
and goes to fancy parties all the way
down
to the street rioter for blm
or antifa why is the regime so nice to
you
why why do corpora the people on the
street
go in break glass and steal nike
sneakers from the nike store and yet
nike supports them
nike makes one of the faces of blm their
corporate spokesman
nike makes woke commercials nike cancel
sneakers that have the american flag on
it even the betsy ross flag
because of its commitment to blm why it
doesn't make sense does it
why on earth does this regime
seem so gung-ho on supporting the people
who are allegedly rebelling against it
because they're not rebelling against it
because this social upheaval this
radical individualism this breaking down
of the
inter intermediating institutions
in the united states serves that
dominant regime
it's it's you you see this when the
parties come and go you saw this with
bush one
clinton bush ii obama the parties come
and go and there's some differences in
policy here and there but what do we
always see
we always see much more global trade
we see much more outsourcing therefore
of our
political rights to super and
international institutions
that control that globe those global
trade arrangements
we see much more immigration we see a
weakening of national borders
we see an erosion of our political
rights which we once had being sent off
to
bureaucrats and technocrats and eggheads
that is the the process and and
so you've got the democratic party which
is the major party in the country
and then you've got these kind of court
jester conservative types who basically
go along with that
and they quibble here and there and they
they argue over which middle eastern
country to bomb
you know the republicans want to bomb
iraq and the democrats want to bomb
afghanistan and so they make a
compromise and they bomb both
but but in terms of actual a challenge
to authority you just don't see it
you just don't see it and when you do
see it you get banned from social media
senator cruz one of the few you know you
really got to give the guy credit i
don't just say this because
we're friends and because we host a
podcast together
he is one of the few conservatives who
is willing to
talk back who's willing to stand up he's
been doing this since he entered the
senate and actually before he entered
the senate
which is why lindsey graham famously
said
if you murdered ted cruz and held the
trial in the u.s senate no one would
vote to convict
what he was saying there is cruz doesn't
get along with all these people who are
part of the swamp this is why cruz and
mcconnell have have
butted heads so many times
and the swamp has a lot of power which
brings us to
our friend liz cheney
liz cheney the embattled house
republican conference leader
so she's in republican leadership she's
at the lowest rung of it but she's still
in the leadership
of the party in the house and they tried
to boot her
a little while ago and they held a
secret vote so they kept her in power
but
she just keeps attacking trump and she
keeps shilling for the left and
more importantly shilling for the
liberal establishment and so now it
looks like she's about to get the boot
at the end of the month
liz cheney to firing one last shot
across the bow one last
chance to to make her point
in the washington post of course in a
very left-wing newspaper
the gop is at a turning point history is
watching us
republicans must decide whether we are
going to choose truth
and fidelity to the constitution in the
immediate wake of the violence of
january 6
almost all of us knew the gravity and
the cause of what had happened
we witnessed it first hand then talking
about how trump is so awful you know
the worst thing ever and how you know in
the old days the republican party was
great but
here democracy is at stake
and then this is the one that really got
me this line that really got me
we must support a parallel bipartisan
review by a commission with subpoena
power to seek facts
and find facts to describe to americans
what happened on january 6th
we should appoint former officials
members of the judiciary and other
prominent americans who can be objective
just as we did after the attacks of
september 11th so comparing
the horn guy jumping on the desk at the
capitol to september 11th
don't forget we were told in the days
just following
the capital riot that that
officers were murdered by the violent
trump supporters and people threw
officer sicknick murdered they threw
a fire extinguisher at his head and
killed him then it turned out that
wasn't true and now even the mainstream
media even the wapo and the new york
times will admit that wasn't true
he actually died very sadly he seems
like a
patriotic good american he died
the following day or within the next
couple of days of a stroke because he
had pre-existing health problems it was
not related
to the violence of that day actually the
only person who was killed
on that day in an act of
actual political violence was ashley
babbitt who was the trump supporter who
was in there
and i'm not even saying that the
officers had no right to defend the
capital but i'm just
if you're talking about the real
violence of that day it was only in one
direction
it was against the trump supporters and
then here's the kicker
the commission should be focused on the
january 6 attacks
the black lives matter and antifa
violence of last summer
was illegal and reprehensible but it was
a different problem
with a different solution okay whatever
blm torches the country for six to eight
months burns down private businesses
private homes government
government buildings to the seats of
temples of our democracy
oh that's another problem for another
day it's not it's not it's not as
urgent it's not but the horn guy jumped
around the capitol
that requires the 911 commission because
that was it was just as bad as 9 11.
right no so that woman she's just
so deeply misguided and her instinct is
always to punch
right and her instinct is always to to
turn against her constituents and her
base
and her instinct is always to shill for
the liberal establishment so it's just
she has no business in leadership
and yet and yet
the republic the republicans can't win
for losing man
the republicans decide they are going to
replace her
with a more liberal republican
ah what the house gop they come out they
say you know
liz cheney she is liberal and relatively
liberal and she's disloyal
yeah you're right i agree with that and
we need to replace her in leadership
totally i absolutely agree with that
with a more liberal republican
yes wait hold on what what was that
right now the name being floated to
replace liz cheney
is elise stefanik i actually i don't
know i don't know if it's stefanic or
stefanik i'm gonna go with stephanie
she's not a very prominent member of the
house right now and i don't think she
should be
because she is one of if not the most
liberal
republican member in the house
repub what are you doing we've been
talking for
weeks more than weeks at this point
about how the republican party and even
the conservative movement they've always
had different elements
they've had the traditional
conservatives and the libertarians and
the war hawk you call them the neocons
and
some populists and this and that isn't
that and the libertarians
they get to lead a lot of the time and
the neocons the war people they get to
lead a lot of the time
but the traditional conservatives they
always go along with the other
constituent parts but they never seem to
lead they never seem to get any headway
so this time i was thinking good we're
going to boot liz cheney we're going to
get an actual conservative in there a
traditional conservative
nope nope we're now going to get
one of the most liberal members of the
house
gets me so agitated i just need some
relief when i need some relief
i check out relief band relief band is
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy
and so much more the product is
100 drug-free non-drowsy provides
all-natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects for as long
as needed how it works is relief band
stimulates a nerve
in your wrist that travels to the part
of the brain that controls
nausea then it blocks the signal your
brain is sending to your stomach
telling you that you are sick there are
a lot of cheapo imitators out there that
don't really do anything
this one totally on the money fda
cleared
as the world's opening backup don't let
the fear of nausea keep you on the
sidelines right now
relief band has an exclusive offer just
from michael knowles show listeners
if you go to reliefband.com use promo
code knowles you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30-day money-back guarantee
so head on over to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com
use our promo code knollscanwles for 20
off plus free shipping
you know every day on my show i talk a
lot about the amazing products and
services from sponsors that i
love and use we want to get to know you
better so that we can choose our
sponsors with you
in mind please go to dailywire.com
knowles and fill out my audience survey
to tell us a little bit more about
yourself to sweeten the whole experience
those of you that complete the survey
will be entered to win a 1
000 gift card but you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show so the
first thing you got to do go to my
my idea my survey you'll be entered to
win a thousand bucks then
if you want to increase your chances of
winning a thousand bucks
go to ben shapiro andrew clavin mount
walsh get access to their surveys as
well
my link is dailywire.com knowles also if
you haven't already joined the daily
wire
you are running out of time because
today thursday may 6th
is the absolute last chance to get 25
off a new membership with code candace
dailywire.com subscribe i candace just
spoke to
former president trump the once and
future president
at least in his mind according to this
interview
go check it out also there was a great
really swarthy brilliant
handsome wonderful guest on this week so
go check out dailywire.com
subscribe we'll be right back with a lot
more
the republicans in the house are poised
to replace
liz cheney who has been disloyal to the
party at crucial moments who has shield
and used left-wing talking points at
crucial moments i agree
she should be replaced they're going to
replace her
with a much more liberal republican
why why i have to why is it because they
think well we have to replace her with a
woman
so at least they replacing liz cheney
with elise stefanik
do you think that identity politics
never entered the minds of people who
were pushing this i bet i bet they did
we have to oh it's just good and we have
to she can't be too conservative
we need to maintain the balance and
that's better and will appeal and the
pollsters and the
focus groups and goodness
gracious me some people have pushed back
they've said well at least elise
stefanik was more loyal to trump
first of all sort of yeah in
recent days she's been more loyal to
trump but
in the early days she was actually quite
anti-trump so i'm not convinced she
seems to me a little bit of a johnny
come lately in that regard but
i'm not even totally interested and
loyal to trump or not loyal to trump i
am interested
certainly in loyal to the people doing
the tough work
people who are showing courage so in
that in that case
trump certainly counts i'm interested in
people who are loyal to the republican
voters and to conservatives sure
what has elise stefanik done to show
that she's loyal to republican voters
she's pro-life that's good but she said
that republicans need to take a more
understanding tone on abortion a more a
more compassionate tone on abortion
a more compassionate tone on abortion is
abortion should be totally illegal
that's compassionate
saying that we ought to be able to kill
babies in some circumstances
is less compassionate i don't think
that's what she meant though i think she
meant we need to go a little squishy on
abortion
well that's no good she criticized trump
for pulling out of the paris climate
accord
she criticized trump's immigration
policies early on she was very happy
when trump
went soft on his immigration policies
she
oh yes she voted for the equality act
she voted for
maybe the most radical piece of
legislation that's ever gone through the
house
she voted for the law that would
redefine
sex itself and totally blur the
distinction between men and women
i i don't she was one of very few
republicans who voted for that to me
that is in itself
totally disqualifying now you might say
michael she voted for it in 2019 but
then she voted against it in 2020.
oh good that makes me feel better she
she has no principles whatsoever and
when she thinks it's advantageous to her
she goes along with
the most radical legislation ever but
then she got a little blowback for it so
then she flips again i'm glad she
flipped i guess but
by the way she flipped when it didn't
really matter
that that's the woman that we're gonna
replace liz cheney with give me a break
guys
the only thing the only thing that makes
me
not totally despondent here with the
idea that you're going to
put this very liberal republican up in
place of liz cheney
is that jake tapper doesn't like her
that's the one that's the one thing i
can hang my hat on and say well at least
if jake tapper doesn't like her she
can't be all that bad former president
trump
is officially endorsing new york
congresswoman elise stefanik
to replace wyoming congresswoman liz
cheney as a member of house republican
leadership cheney
essentially is being purged because she
refused to lie
about the 2020 election and the january
6 insurrection
stefanik on the other hand is a fierce
trump loyalist she not only has been
willing to spread the big lie
she voted to disenfranchise nearly seven
million pennsylvanians
after the insurrection based on those
lies
the big lie it's the big lie you know
the big lie
liz cheney talks about the big lie and
all the democrats talk about the big lie
is the bit what's the big lie
well the big lie is a phrase that
the left has used to attack donald trump
and compare him to hitler
because hitler coined the term the big
lie in monconf
however because the libs know just like
a very little bit about history but they
don't know
it's i'm not even saying i know a ton
about history i know just like a little
tiny sliver more than they do
you know like i actually have read a
book or two i haven't even read like
three books i'm just saying it's like
one or two that's all you need to know
to realize that in the libs analogy here
they are making themselves out to be the
nazis
because when when hitler used the phrase
the big lie in mineconf
he was not referring to his own strategy
to take over
the culture he was actually accusing the
jews of propagating a big lie
uh by blaming the german laws in world
war one on the german general eric
ludendorff
so they don't they're not even aware
that when they use this phrase they are
casting themselves
in the position of hitler or the nazis
but what's the big lie
you heard jake tapper say he said she
this at least stefanik she suggested
disenfranchising pennsylvanians
who were participating in a totally
aboveboard election and there was
nothing questionable about that at all
regardless of what you think about the
2020 election i know i've got to be very
careful here no one can ever question
any aspect of the election i'm just
making the
incontrovertible observation that the
supreme court of pennsylvania
well forget the supreme court for a
second because the supreme court
actually had some political problems
the constitution of pennsylvania
prohibits no excuse male in balance
prohibits the widespread use of the
mail-ins that typified that election
that was not just illegal it was
unconstitutional there
so if stefanik is going to point that
out that's good
it's a good thing that's i'm i'm
starting to like her a little bit more
as a leader of the republican party
still not willing to elevate someone who
has a very very liberal record
to leadership again in the republican
party it's just same
same verse same as the first
but what what tapper is calling out here
is preposterous
now is anyone allowed to make that point
if does jake tapper invite me on his
show no he never has i'm not complaining
about it
i'm not not saying i'm totally
interested in spending my time on cnn
but i suppose i would go on
because the thing is i watch cnn clips
and i notice they never seem to have
any actual conservatives
this is very strange because jake tapper
right now is threatening
not to allow republicans on his show
anymore
he made this he made this threat
yesterday on cnn he said you know i
i don't if if they keep up like this i'm
not going to have republicans on anymore
i don't think it's healthy for the
country to only have a debate between
the left and the far left
we need a thriving republican party we
need
an argument a counter-argument no i
think this is not me but
we need a republican party saying no i
think that
six trillion dollars in new spending is
a bad idea and here's here's why
no i think that subsidized daycare uh
is the wrong way to go for our culture
and here's why these are not again my
arguments these are arguments that
conservatives would make
okay great we need those debates having
happening
but we can't have those debates if
one side of the argument is not willing
to stick to
standards and facts for
for a whole host of reasons one of them
is how am i supposed to believe
anything they say if they're willing to
lie about joe biden wanting to steal
your hamburgers
and queuing on and the big lie about the
election
what are they not willing to lie about
why should i put any of them on tv
the big lie the big lie the big lie
notice what jake tapper says here he
says look we need a republican party
to argue over spending look we need a
republican party to argue over the
implementation of various welfare
programs he doesn't say we need a
republican party to
advocate for drastically reduced
immigration
that would be beyond the pale that would
be beyond jake's standards
he doesn't say we need a republican
party to argue that
christianity is the basis of our country
going going back to the mayflower
and that obviously this country was
shaped from christianity from the west
broadly and from an anglo-political
tradition
you're not remember you're not allowed
to use that phrase anymore no he
wouldn't that would be so beyond the
pale
we just need good little republicans to
come on the show
and kind of argue about oh you're
spending a little too much money and we
should actually
we should our taxes should be a little
bit different than that but
but we don't need a republican party to
actually challenge the liberal
establishment
we won't permit that when jake tapper
said he's not going to have any any
republicans on his show
i thought okay
what's changing when was the last time
you saw a conservative
an actual conservative i'm not i'm not
just taking
pot shots and saying you're everyone to
the left of me is a rhino or i'm not i'm
not i'm actually i'm just saying
there are republicans who have a
conservative
vision of the world who begin with
different philosophical premises than
liberals
and there are many republicans who share
the exact same philosophical premises as
liberals
and basically the same progressive
understanding of history and politics
they just kind of quibble over the
details
and cnn does a great job of having
liberals come on liberal republicans or
liberal conservatives right
people who you know they want to
conserve they want to go a little bit
slower they don't want to go quite as
fast down the road of progress but they
still share the progressive view but
they do a very poor job with very few
exceptions they do a very poor job of
having
actual conservatives on so
what's going to change nothing's going
to change because listen to what jake
tapper said there he said
we it's we can't even agree on the facts
well
yeah right because cnn's a propaganda
outlet for the left and so
they'll push a lot of lies like the
russia hoax and myriad other hoaxes
and sure some republicans go on and they
have their spin doctors too and okay
that's fine but that's not really the
issue the issue
jake admits it the issue is standards
standards ah there it is
the left has a vision of standards in
this country
facebook is going to enforce certain
standards google and twitter
and if you contradict those standards
even if you're the duly elected sitting
president of the united states a year
out
and conservatives heretofore for the for
the past 20 years or so
have argued that we should have no
standards whatsoever
they've actually adopted the left's
arguments from the 1960s
that we need we need for total free
speech man total free love
total you do you if it feels good do it
right we've just adopted
all the radical left premises from 50 60
years ago
and now we're shocked to find out that
society doesn't really work that way
that society always has standards that
society always says guard reels that
society always recognizes that some
things cannot be done and cannot be said
and that's been true going back to the
earliest days of america it's been true
everywhere on earth
i explain this process in my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now
for pre-order as you might remember you
can also get an autographed first
edition copy at premiere collectibles
that is simply the case and if
conservative
i hate to argue that conservatives
should
listen to cnn every so often very you
know in very
small doses and then you know turn it
off to preserve your sanity
but you you really should consider not
just listening to cnn
but reading the radical leftists who
created
this dominant regime that we're living
in actually if you want you can just
read it in my upcoming book because
that's
that's where i talk about that history
does that it's not a separate plug i was
still doing the same thing
i'll argue with the judges later on
after the show
that is the world that we live in okay
we're living in the world of the leftist
standards and it's a kind of
anti-standard and it's a
very perverse standard it's and it's
ridiculous but if
we don't put forward our own standards
then we're just going to keep in this
vicious cycle
we're just it's going to be like house
republican leadership it's good we
complain about the
the lib in house republican leadership
and then we boot out the lib and we
replace them with another lib
because we don't understand how to get
out of that vicious cycle
there are bigger problems here than just
the stalemate that we've been in over
the last 20 or so years where it seems
like we no matter what we do no matter
who we elect we can't
win no matter how hard we push against
political correctness we can't we always
seem to seed ground
there were deeper problems here well
we're all busy arguing
like jake tapper says over we're
spending a little too much money and
you know we're spending a little too
much on welfare or whatever
here's a here's a an existential
political problem for the country
the birth rate is falling again the
birth rate has been falling steadily for
a long time
and it fell again it fell four percent
in the year 2020. we were told that
there was going to be a baby boom
remember the covid baby boom i actually
participated in the cove baby boom
we were told we were hoping that there
would be a baby boom but there wasn't
the birth rate fell again four percent
uh this is the lowest point since
federal health officials started
tracking it more than a century ago
3.6 million babies were born in the
united states last year that's down from
3.75 million in 2019.
in 2007 just for perspective 4.3 million
babies were born the nation is now below
replacement levels according to the cdc
that means that more people are dying
every day than are being born
we are a dying nation something has gone
horribly wrong
and you can't only blame the left for
that you might you might blame the left
for
causing that you might blame the left
for instigating that you might blame the
left even for desiring that they clearly
don't like the country very much
they're pushing the 1619 project that
says it's an evil country they're
literally burning it to the ground
through blm and antifa
they're saying that our whole system of
justice is perverse and the physical
representation that the cops
need to be abolished they are
disrespecting the american flag on
sports teams
on in professional sports in halls of
power
so yeah they might be cheering that on
and they actively are by the way you've
got
looney tunes like bill gates saying
without any evidence whatsoever that
we've got a
overpopulation problem and we therefore
need to push abortion we need to push
contraception they've been saying this
since the 70s
when they said inevitably there will be
mass famines and a population bomb
we will actually need to coerce paul
ehrlich said this in his book population
mob we might need to coerce abortion and
contraception
what happened 50 years later the popular
world population has doubled
malnutrition is an all-time low it's a
total lie but they seem to desire this
sort of thing
but conservatives let it happen
conservatives let it
be rolled over by playing the court
jester conservative in the kingdom of
liberalism by playing along with their
game by not putting forward
an actual alternative in the word of
phyllis schlafly
we need a choice not an echo and yet
what have we given nothing
nothing but echoes echo echo echo in
this
aging country and an aging culture
the aging country has a very
aging president i think biden biden is
the perfect president for us right now
he i didn't vote for him i was very sad
when he ascended to the presidency
but he's he's the perfect representative
of where the country's at right now
if i if i had to describe
the national ethos right now if i had to
perform what the country looks like i
bet it would sound a lot like this
job creation is soaring the economy is
growing and our country is on the move
again
but some of the parts of the of our
economy special help
at the top of that list is our nation's
restaurants
when covet 19 pandemic struck our
nation's restaurants were
some of the first hit and the worst hit
in 2020 more than 2
300 just me 2 million 2.3 million
restaurants jobs disappeared 2.3 million
restaurant jobs disappeared
restaurants are more than a major driver
of our economy
they're woven in the fabric of our
communities
and then there's two and uh well it's uh
coming on
uh seminar who now where am i
what's uh hey oh hey there hey come on
man
what's going on biden not a whole lot
going on in between the ears i think
that's pretty clear though that's always
been the case with bite people forget
this they think
they think he was sharp as attack 10
years ago because he spoke more clearly
but the guy has always been a doofus
i don't even say that to throw bombs or
be insulting he was always considered a
doofus in american politics he was
considered a doofus in the democratic
party and now
he's older so you know we don't want to
be too insulting of him and he's
obviously lost a step
but beyond the question of
what what he's had going on the whole
time he just seems exhausted and we seem
exhausted as a country
but i'm not exhausted i don't know about
you i'm not exhausted
i'm raring to go i want to do stuff
i i have not fallen into this
existential on we
this malaise that seems to have taken
over the culture
i want to do stuff i want to build stuff
i want to
have kids i want to have a thriving
community
i want to enjoy the beautiful world i
want
i want to not just miss what we have
lost i want to not just engage in
nostalgia which
is history after a few drinks but i want
to enjoy what we still have
and what we could pull back again and i
think a lot of conservatives
agree with me and i think that this was
the whole premise of donald trump's 2016
campaign
and it's why it was so effective despite
any flaws and foibles he might have had
because his argument was make america
great again not
let's just be kind of comfortable not oh
we should really feel bad about all the
stuff that in the past
and not we need to have fewer kids
because the earth and the sun monster
and the global
whatever cooling warming change whatever
it's not that he said no no
be great make america great again
there's a great scene in that movie hail
caesar
possibly the greatest movie of the last
10 years it's a cohen brothers movie it
didn't didn't do as well as it should
have
and in this movie george clooney plays
george clooney and
he actually he this is quite a
coincidence unintentional
he falls under the sway of
a professor of the frankfurt school and
the father of the new left herbert
marcus who i talk about on this show and
who i talk about at great length in my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds held on that for
pre-order that one
wow i'm even i'm even fooling myself on
some of these ad transitions now
clooney falls under the sway of this
radical marxist herbert marcus and he
shows up
in the office of eddie mannix who's the
big studio head in hollywood
and he says oh man you don't understand
we're just all
in this awful terrible system and it's
the fat cats exploiting us and
is terrible for us and we gotta throw
off our shackles and the studio chief
pulls him up smacks him in the face
and he says don't you ever say that
again this studio's been good to you
that fat cat in new york he's been good
to you he's the founder of your feasts
and he's enabled you to do great things
and i don't want to ever hear you say
that again
and and the george clooney character he
looks shocked and he says okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry
and he walked starts to walk out of the
office dejected and eddie mannix the the
boss in the room turns to him he says
hey go be a star
that's why i think come on just cut it
out with the
ridiculous being critical of everything
tearing down the statues
ripping down george washington go out
there and be a star
can we do that or are we a dying
population that's up to us
it's up to us are we going to lean into
society it's why i'm so
personally offended by the gates divorce
it's not because i particularly care
about
bill and melinda gates but it's because
when you get divorced that's not just a
private matter
it's a public matter because marriage is
a public institution it's why you do it
in public it's why you register it with
the government that's why it's always
it's the fundamental political
institution and when you pull out of
that
it's not just about you man it's not
just about you moving on to the next
phase of your life and growing
individually and
it's about society it's about providing
a stable home for your children
and it's about providing a stable basis
for your community and for your state
and for your country
i get it it's a fallen world these
things are going to happen but we should
discourage it
we shouldn't celebrate it which is what
we're doing now
that's insane that's going to lead to
much bigger political problems
like the dying population and the
consequent
desire for immigration to keep the
economy afloat
and the falling apart of our
ability for self-government and are
outsourcing it to the virtuous
self-styled benevolent bettors in
washington dc
we've got a frail president in a frail
country but it doesn't have to be that
way joe rogan
came out joe rogan one of the seriously
one of the thought leaders in our
country
i'm not saying that ironically he he is
i don't know if what it says about our
country but he is
he pointed out the other day he said you
know i wanted to send a video around
that i saw uh of
questioning the narrative on the
coronavirus and the lockdowns and the
treatment
but i couldn't send it even through a
private message you know i tried to send
a friend of mine a video the other day
on twitter
through a direct message and it was
blocked really
i couldn't send a direct message it's it
was
i was asking him if this was accurate
and it was a
doctor who's talked about ivermectin an
ivermectin which is a um
it's a treatment for covet and this
doctor was saying that
ivermectin is 99 effective in treating
covit
but that you don't hear about it because
you can't fund
vaccines when there's an effective
treatment
and this is i don't know if this guy's
right or wrong so i'm asking questions
so i go hey tell me about this so i send
it
it message not sent i tried to send it
again message not sent i'm like oh my
god what's your email
i had to send it through email gotta
send it through email now i don't know
anything about ivermectin i don't even
really care that much
that's not that's not what interests me
in this clip what interests me in this
clip is
joe rogan a famous powerful rich guy
couldn't send a private message just
asking
a scientific question couldn't engage in
science
couldn't try to follow the science
because the the country the culture is
being run by a cartel
it's being run by these mobsters this
little corporate oligarchy in silicon
valley that's working with the
establishment
all over the place that is very
different than our constitutional system
purports to be on paper are we gonna
are we gonna assert our political right
and begin to exercise self-government
again
are we just going to say ah man whatever
move into the frail old age of our
republic and say whatever man it is what
it is
the choice is ours i'm michael and also
the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show after facebook's
oversight board backs the company's ban
on donald trump
democrats call for more the biden
administration keeps playing politics
with covet
and kamala harris makes out with her
husband through a mask that's today on
the bench shapiro show give it a listen